[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment oser l'air et bien ça faisait
longtemps que je vous avais promis dans
un événement pour les découvre de
nouvelles choses et aujourd'hui on va
parler automobile
il est tout juif 7h12 du mat
on va les nouvelles voitures des
nouvelles voitures volkswagen de prades
électrique on va regarder comment ils se
connectent regarder tous âges la connais
pas donc vraiment un livre ça c'est
l'idée quatre ans après beaucoup de
pareilles d'automobiles heartwire si ça
peut vous intéresser dès maintenant on
va en commentaires si vous voulez qu'on
en parle un peu plus pas aujourd'hui la
voiture la technologie aucun lié aux
smartphones et bien tout s'imbrique dans
un écosystème vie numérique plein de
choses qu'on peut faire avec ça fait
très plaisir pouvoir repartir en tension
et vous reprendre l'aventuré qui
déjeunaient dans la chambre comme it
faisant mais en tout cas on va bien se
marrer
[Musique]
alors mal programme qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui pour laisser on part de là
on est au golf international de roissy
on va jeter un peu de tout tac tac on
bifurque soit la départementale on monte
jusqu ici verdien petit parcours qui va
se faire et ensuite on continue on va
longer la côte
je pense qu'avoir des images sont être
très sympa un poids de recherche or des
sens sur l'autoroute et puis après on
redescend et sans paillettes
je suis un peu bas qui en arrière ça
c'est quoi ça ça c'est jeu de clés des
petits bonbons une eau minérale
naturelle c'est formidable là j'ai mon
affichage là qu'est démarrage démarrage
démarrage
ah c'est pas mal ça va réalité augmentée
la droite dans ces fluides et les demis
ça c'est pas mal ça me met sur l'écran
j'ai tout vu tout à l'heure la cause
c'est un peu compliqué ça se rapproche
objectif
[Musique]
c é praille prat viable dès janvier sur
l'électrique l'électrique est silencieux
il ya un couple de malades et que
j'appuie sa part c'est ça c'est
vachement cool qui est super intéressant
c'est surtout toute la partie software
tout ce qu'on peut utiliser c'est
vraiment l'expérience que je vais mettre
en avant et que je vais vous montrer
mais quand je serai arrêtée parce que là
je conduis et bien évidemment il faut
faire attention on va pas se faire un
peu faire n'importe quoi le fait d'avoir
la batterie dans le plancher
ça vient vraiment là soir d' avantages
dont ils super tenue de route
donc c'est pas moi qui vais vous parler
du couple moteur pas moi qui vous parle
et de l'autonomie la tuque mais pour moi
ce qui est vraiment génial c'est toute
la connectivité toute l'expérience que
vous pouvez régler le fait d'avoir la
réalité augmentée sainte qui à ses yeux
film en fait lorsque vous allez mettre
la navigation vous voyez une toute
petite flèche elle dit à s'agrandir pour
venir faut tourner et retourner la photo
mais là ça je trouve ça vraiment
vraiment bien c'est très immersif on
peut le régler en hauteur comme ça c'est
pareil ça soit dans beaucoup de
véhicules toute l'expérience joue du
logiciel avait vraiment folle je vous la
montrer le temps qu'on se pose un petit
peu l'habitacle est très grand ça c'est
super agréable or au début ça m'a un peu
déstabilisé parce que moi j'ai
l'habitude de conduire une thermique
on n'est pas du tout sur ce type de
véhicule l'a donc se retrouver avec le
levier de pas levier de vitesse mais
levier de commande pour enclencher des
marais neutre et qui est planqué en
autres c'est un peu bizarre j'ai eu un
peu de mal au début à comprendre comment
ça marche et pour mettre la radio et
compagnie j'ai fini par comprendre en
fait c'est extrêmement intuitif
j'en suis qu'au début ça fait quoi une
petite torche je roule j'ai encore pas
mal de bande l et brest deux heures pour
arriver jusqu'à notre premier stop
[Musique]
vous avez un état d' on avec antoine
arqués chef de produit des services
digitaux chez volkswagen salle entonne
ouais super jeu qu'on parle de cette
nouvelle quand on t'appelle id4 ideapad
k1 heidi 4 kg a battu mix l'anglais
français c'est ça les dégâts ok alors
cette année 10,4 en termes de
connectivité
qu'est ce qu'elle raconte en fait comme
histoire en fait on est sur un
écosystème chez volkswagen qui va
s'articuler donc autour des services oui
on appelle ça les ouïes service is ok et
donc grâce à des applications on va
pouvoir avoir tout un écosystème dans le
véhicule qui va permettre de recharger
son véhicule d'avoir une interaction
avec le véhicule
on peut avoir des éclairages d'ambiance
ouais ça tu peux je vous pouvez le
change et les éclairages d'ambiance de
l'intérieur c'est ça ok exactement on a
aussi ce qu'on appelle la ville ait donc
dans le véhicule au niveau du pare brise
on va avoir un éclairage qui va être en
relation avec la navigation par exemple
au quai des cageux la défilé quand même
falloir tourner à droite
quand un appel entrant ouais je vais
avoir une lumière verte qui va
s'afficher hockey et donc qu'il va
pouvoir
répondre et également grâce à la
commande vocale l'idée c'est quoi c'est
en fait c'est d'attraper l'attention de
la personne sont le distrait la route
c'est ça exactement
ok on garde en fait la vision sur la
route tout en ayant tout une
interactivité pardon avec deux véhicules
pendant la partie véhicule ou là on va
pouvoir revoir tout ce qu'on veut sur le
véhicule donc la gestion des
rétroviseurs la gestion des six glaces
la gestion de la recharge
on va pouvoir avoir l'aspect navigation
on a tous deux les ventes de recharge
tous les voit comment les bornes de
recharge et si on fait alors du coup on
va sur la carte
ouais ici on va voir tous les points
d'intérêt et quand
on sommet un peu moins proche on va voir
les points de recharge à proximité donc
l'a22 kilowatts ça s'indigne par exemple
hockey et ensuite donc on va voir tout
ce qui est connectivité dont cap
connecte donc là c'est apple qui a
rappelé je peux venir connecter
directement connectée mon iphone ici
exactement
ok ensuite on a tout ce qui est ambiance
donc ça veut dire que ça je peux venir
changer ici là au fait tu as raison ok
ça s'est corsé les ambiances ça on a les
ambiances prédéfinis au fort ya en fait
ça me change quoi ça me change qui s'y
passe que dans le reste de la voiture ça
ne change pas les couleurs sur les
bandeaux lumineux
il est comme qui parcourt tout
l'habitacle ok donc on va voir des
lumières d'ambiance différentes hockey à
la partie climatisation également des
aspects classiques on va dire et sinon
on a smart climate qui va donner en fait
des pré configuration
parce que pour chauffer les mains
voilà c'est ça avec le véhicule il
intègre la technologie carte physx d'une
carte musique ça permet de communiquer
entre les véhicules donc indiquer s'il
ira temps s'il ya un embouteillage par
exemple voyait plus les véhicules vont
avoir cette technologie de cartoons x
plus la conduite sur route va être en
toute sécurité
étant donné qu'on va voir toutes les
informations en temps réel dans le
véhicule
ces véhicules qu'ils vont communiquer
entre eux c'est sa communication entre
eux est possible du coup de freinage
adaptatif avec le véhicule s'il ya un
forfait
mais ça c'est qu'une qu'entre paul le
guen ça c'est pour l'instant c'est
qu'entre vaudry halloween et après ça
peut être amené à être sur des véhicules
notre marque aussi parce que c'est des
choses où il ya un lien avec la 5g ou
pas du tout où c'est vraiment que les
voitures à proximité qui arriva avec
quelques lcsa exact règles afin que
toutes les tous les véhicules équipés de
cartes sim chez nous communique donc
avec le réseau en kart ou six là on à
l'application wiconnect heidi qui va
permettre de gérer son véhicule à
distance ou gérer la recharge gérer la
climatisation et avoir les données de
recharge et véhicule ou là par exemple
moi je suis connecté sur une heidi 3 ça
fonctionne sur les allées du iv
également dumont a dit roy est là encore
184 km la technique à distance
exactement c'est vraiment l'état de ta
voiture
oui c'est ça le climat moins cher que
l'achat 184 km d'autonomie
je peux régler la climatisation et
ensuite quand je vais sur l'aspect
véhicule on peut gérer la climatisation
choisir son heure de départ
dans ces cas là si je mets une aire de
départ par exemple à 8 heures demain
matin
le véhicule va se réchauffer pour se
préparer 2008 quand il est branché à ta
bornes de recharge par exemple chez toi
ou alors d'après vous qui lance le
chauffage c'est moins énergivores sur la
route comme ça tu gardes plus
d'autonomie et donc on peut aussi
démarré la recharge à distance si ma
voiture est branchée bornes de recharge
sur courant ça c'est comme si on le
système d'infotainment du véhicule donc
on à la carte avec les 22 recharge à
dispo donc à proximité ici on a deux
bandes disponibles vos clés sont en gris
c'est qu'elles ne sont pas disponibles
ci s en rouge ça veut dire qu'à s'en
occuper et derrière on peut avoir donc
le tarif et les disponibilités et en
plus on peut envoyer par exemple à mon
véhicule
la destination et ça va envoyer
directement la navigation dans le
véhicule
et sinon la dernière donc grosse
fonctionnalités cwi charge
oui charge c'est ce qui permet du coup
de payer les recharges en déplacement et
aussi de gérer son application et sa
vente de recharges avec l'application
donc on peut gérer donc sans saveur de
recharge à domicile grâce à
l'application choisir quand et des
marcquois n'aggravent pas aussi gérer
l'accessibilité de la gorge vous avez en
assistant vocal de l'intérieur de la
boîte tracteurs véhicules
donc quand tu rends dans le véhicule tu
peux dire bonjour heidi là le véhicule
va te répond ok derrière tu as plein de
possibilités donc il peut appeler un ami
tu peux lancer ta stations de radio
préférées qui peut faire beaucoup de
choses
est ce que l'idée c'est d'aller aussi
loin que ce que peuvent proposer des
solutions comme google syrie ce genre de
choses ça c'est pourquoi est ce que vous
le monde alors je question un peu un peu
technophiles mais on aurait tendance à
se dire pourquoi est-ce qu'une marque va
pas chercher à intégrer une solution
comme solution d'apple solution google
pour intégrer une expérience qui
permettra d'aller beaucoup plus loin
est ce que c'est parce que les
écosystèmes sont différents au niveau de
l'android de noël de laïos est ce qu on
pourrait avoir les deux à l'intérieur
est-ce que nativement tu vois sans avoir
cette solution qui est propre
aujourd'hui à volkswagen
mais l'idée c'est vraiment de recentrer
en fait toute l'expérience autour d'un
même écosystème
ok donc du coup on va arriver sur des
produits sur des services qui vont être
en relation tous ensemble des services
ne sont pas encore lancés qui vont
arriver plus tard dans les années à
venir
ils vont être tous ceux en relation
ensemble donc ça va être pour la
recharge ça va être de l'expérience
autour du véhicule
donc tout ça ça va venir petit à petit
s'ajouter autour du véhicule et ça va
amener une expérience globale en fait
autour du véhicule
et oui on est sur une vision faite à
long terme là dessus pour réussir à
réinventer c'est ça en fait on va
chercher non plus à avoir
une expérience de d'auto mobilité mais
une expérience de mobilité
mc on était bien de prévoir le soleil
était possible et rm soul a pu elle son
père d'un bien tu peux me dire comment
tu t'appelles qu'il était alors je suis
mathias ducatel j'écris pour bloc moteur
points communs photo un média qui existe
depuis dix ans est plutôt orienté
voitures sportives par les voitures qui
font romeu quoi c'est bien vous qu'est
ce que tu penses de lévis quatre toiles
dont les premiers retours là alors mon
premier retour est plutôt positif alors
ce que j'ai eu l'occasion d'essayer la
vie des trois il ya quelques mois de ça
ouais donc
ce que je trouve par rapport à vis des
trois c'est qu'on conserve un petit peu
les mêmes les mêmes prérequis en termes
de présentation intérieure
par contre là la finition est un petit
peu haut de gamme afin de constituer en
terme de matériaux utilisés ok la
planche de bord ça fait plus plus qu'ali
ça fait vraiment assez sympa je trouve
qu'il ya montée en gamme pour dire les
choses autrement
bernard de conduite c'est vraiment
toujours aussi agréable
quel centre de gravité qui est assez
bonne voiture qui qui vire à plat qui
est agréable à conduire à fin mai est un
signe que ça et surtout qui est assez
confortable
au final messi lui barre le point
négatif après lequel en point négatif
j'ai trouvé qu'il ya peut-être on
s'emploie supérieur par rapport à l'idée
3way des accélérations un peu moins vive
a forcément puisque a plus de pouvoir
emmener mes mecs ils ont globalement
c'est une voiture que je trouve un petit
peu plus sérieuse un peu plus mature
justement que que l'idée 3 salut tu sais
pas comment tu fais quoi alors je
m'appelle william k et je suis la
photographe et accessoirement était
asocial ok ça marche donc la statue de
swiebodzin guen pour faire les photos
des produits
ouais j'ai compris alors toi c'est quoi
ton et sur ce produit je le trouve hyper
intéressant alors j'avais déjà eu
l'occasion de foot et là et 10 3
précédemment
et je trouvais que ce renouveau en
termes de design qui se rapproche un peu
de lignes un peu futuriste
je trouve ça hyper intéressant je
m'occupe tous les âges vous de petites
lumières d'ambiance c'est là ça donne
vraiment ça donne vraiment une vraie
ambiance visuelle à l'intérieur du
véhicule et à l'extérieur je trouve les
lignes hyper bien travaillé je trouve
que les phares donne vraiment un aspect
un peu un peu agressif j'aime j'aime
beaucoup tout les tous les ajouts en
termes de design et du mordant quoi
ouais exactement il ya du mordant et en
plus de ça c'est relativement simple si
je puis dire de faire de jolies photos
d'avis
il réussit hyper bien la lumière
naturelle c'est un bonheur à
photographier par sa cellule du
professionnel qui parlent même là même
la vie visuelle au global je sais c'est
pas c'est pas évident de réussir à
choper une jolie photo d'un véhicule ça
va beaucoup dépendre du design et moi
j'aime beaucoup
ok gardez ça comme c'est mignon là la
vue qu'on a dit si c'est absolument
incroyable
en fait le spot où on a mangé la
s'appelle avis à quoi et la ville à quoi
c'est plutôt cool
alors bon ici le temps aujourd'hui fin
complètement dingue et un petit bout de
piscine derrière il ya les voitures là
bas on a bien mangé et puis bon il est
temps de reprendre la route
là il ya eu beaucoup de départementale
maintenant on va se faire un bout
d'autoroute on va tester la charge
7 quel mot là dedans parcours autour
bon je pense comme ça non n'ont ils pas
lancé non
donc là j'ai mon appui et provale repas
voilà est en fait si on va m'aider les
états mais oui bien sûr merci beaucoup
merci à lui
[Musique]
regardez le spot que je vous ai trouvé
la regarder le suppose que je vous ai
trouvé assez pas mal garées là c'est la
manche derrière ça caille hang seng goya
b3
là on peut dire que si jeune et ça c'est
très très cool impressionnant la
regardez moi ces falaises c'est super
beau en même temps c'est un peu de
tourisme
ça c'est hyper agréable et puis bon
voilà toujours l'idée qu'être gay la
coucou toi
messi
badigeonnez
à nos pieds
[Musique]
m
la musique
au vent le vent le vent le vent le vent
carles est ce que j'adore ici dans cette
voiture c'est ça la sas est très cool
parce que ça vous convient d'avoir de la
lumière partout vous posez là vous voyez
le ciel véhicule
si je me mets dans l'habitacle tavillons
réglage du pavillon suisse a regardé la
bon moi je veux pas un truc fermé en
fait ça me plaît bien tout ouvert donc
ça c'est ça c'est cool j'adore ces
petits chemins dans le marais ça me
plaît beaucoup
regardez l'a pas vu elle est délirante
et là on peut quand on a commencé à
prendre le chemin que les cailloux je me
suis dit c'est une blague ils sont
trompés et ben non c'est pas une blague
c'est un spot qui est incroyable pour
filmer pour faire des photos des vidéos
ça c'est génial et pour essayer la
voiture en mode 4 4 c'est un suv ce
n'est pas un 4 4
je peux pas le préciser eh ben on peut
quand même le faire c'est le marais alb
aux supras choix tu es là regardez là
vous voyez la somme indique avec la
réalité augmentée qu'il faut que je
tourne donc la regarder la pop
j'avance j'avance j'ai toujours mon
indications mon éducation
elle va grandir pour jeu tout le monde
regarde et la voilà la grande île de
montviel andy a grandi a grandi a grandi
a grandi et hop voilà
et là elle va disparaître
les yeux
je vais profiter d'une petite pause sur
l'autoroute pour recharger la voiture
pour vous montrer un peu les
fonctionnalités qu'on a
d'un point de vue purement software
parce que c'est un truc qui m'intéresse
ce qui va m'intéresser moi c'est bien
c'est la partie véhicule là je suis en
train de recharger donc ça me marque
effectivement mon temps de recharge de
compagnie pour haïti la recharge mais
non j'ai encore un petit peu besoin dans
l'habitacle peut régler l'affichage tête
haute c'est d'ailleurs ce qui va
s'afficher sur l'écran en réalité
augmentée donc je peut l'activer à
désactiver je vois la position je peux
venir la montée un petit peu plus aux
tonalités sas et paramétrage de son
focus si vous voulez plus ou moins de
musique à l'avant l'arrière ça c'est
plutôt marrant parce qu'on comprend en
fait ça serait assez intuitive voyez on
comprend très bien comment on vient cas
les leçons alors après tout qu'est pas
mal c'est que j'ai différents modes moi
je me suis mis en mode confort par
défaut tout ce qui va être assistant ce
qu'on peut venir régler ça ce constat
aussi pas mal vraiment vous venez quel
est votre front assist qui va venir vous
assistez pour par rapport à tous les
véhicules que vous avez devant il va
vous avertir à ces taux moyen tard ou
carrément le désactiver si vous voulez
assistant d'évitement tout ce côté là
c'est vraiment sur la sécurité où ça
vraiment pas mal
prévision du tracé du trajet il ya pas
mal de petites de petits réglages le
side assist sur le changement de voie
c'est pareil ça c'est vraiment pas trop
mal et c'est quoi c'est un café
détection de fatigue activé au quesnoy
inotes il ya un truc que je trouve pas
mal sur le volant c'est qu'en fait il si
la wii pour venir naviguer ça vient
changer ici au niveau de votre écran
lorsque je fais des filets vous avez un
retour haptique ce qui fait que vous le
sentez sous le doigt sentais comme si
vous aviez une petite matière vous avez
pas besoin de regarder vous mettez votre
doigt vous le centre c'est vraiment
pratique donc là c'est pour naviguer ici
et vous avez également les modes lavoyer
pour le
régulateur de vitesse ou pour le
limiteur et bien vous le sentez
également de la même manière là donc ça
côté retour haptique sousse a assez mal
j'en profite des faits sur cette petite
pause pour faire un tour du véhicule
comme ça vous pouvez regarder puis dire
tout ce que vous en pensez un bar aux
commentaires poignées j'aime bien c'est
vachement discret et là vous avez le
petit volkswagen qui écrit là bon c'est
pas mal y'a rien qui bouge en fait ça
c'est assez sympa je sais pas le marron
comme ça pourquoi pas une question de
gauche
jamais un côté tissu un peu bâclé sur
cette finition à ça c'est assez sympa à
l'arrière pareils qu'on fasse un petit
tour regarder rapidement qui porte
gobelets
j'ai une petite trappe pour avoir accès
à mon coffre donc là j'ai un petit fils
et un parapluie ont tout prévu
et s'il une autre app donc je peux à
différentes profondeurs au niveau du
volume du coffre est en dessous de colas
tous les cas pour la recharge
voilà qui va être là
[Musique]
donc pour cette journée à essayer
découvrir nouvelle électrique de
volkswagen pour moi c'est une première
je connaissais pas du tout ce modèle là
de volkswagen j'avais jamais céder les
tricks de volkswagen ça plutôt
intéressant plutôt cool donc je serai
contente alors si je débriefait je vais
dire que sur toute la partie
expérientiel moi j'ai bien aimé le
véhicule en lui-même
moi ce qui m'a vraiment interpellé
intéressés ça vous le savez j'aime latex
et surtout la partie connectivité
comment est ce qu'on arrive à faire le
pont entre votre voiture
eva smartphone ça ça m'intéresse
vraiment l'idée que l'application qu'on
s'a vraiment très mal
l'idée aussi une fois programmez votre
voiture pour qu'elle soit prête au
moment où vous voulez partir matin ça
c'est aussi super malin si je trouve
aussi intéressant est ce qui est plutôt
pas mal ce qu on a super rayon de
braquage je trouve maniable en ville
elle se conduit bien sûr l'autoroute
nickel sur les petits chemins ça allait
très bien à vous mais qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vous en bas en commentaire
comment vous le trouvez cette idée heidi
4 c'est marrant c'est à dire jeudi des 4
ou iphone ont saisi 4 comment la trouvez
c'est à 10,4 de volkswagen est ce que
vous croyez électrique et sur
l'électrique ça vous intéresse et si oui
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter par un bel et par véhicule
électrique de volkswagen marques et
bassa en bas on commence je trouve
extrêmement rapidement
parce que oui bien évidemment il ya
plein de choses à raconter et merci
bonne moyenne pour la petite automobile
ça fera plaisir est un lieu qui va bien
s'amuser avec voilà des bisous très vite
ciao